C'è una cosa che mi ha colpito
profondamente. Anni fa un'azienda
giapponese ha fatto una conferenza
stampa non per un nuovo prodotto, non
per una nuova acquisizione, per chiedere
scusa perché per la prima volta in 25
anni avevano alzato il prezzo di un
gelato di 10 yen, cent di euro, e si
sono inchinati davanti alle telecamera
con le la faccia piena di vergogna a
chiedere perdono ai consumatori
giapponesi. E noi occidentali potremmo
pensare "Ma questo è uno scherzo?" No,
non è uno scherzo. Questo è il Giappone,
un paese dove i prezzi non si muovevano
da 30 anni, dove il riso costava uguale
nel 2020, come nel 1995, dove un mutuo
lo pagavi allo 0 vir qualcosa pero, dove
l'inflazione non esisteva, era un
concetto alieno, come la neve nel
deserto. Bene, adesso quel paese,
proprio quel paese che si scusava per 6
centesimi su un gelato, appena ha fatto
qualcosa che non succedeva da 40 anni,
ha fatto esplodere il più grande mercato
obbligazionario del pianeta in 18 ore e
le conseguenze arriveranno fin da noi,
sui nostri risparmi, sui nostri
portafogli di investimento, sui nostri
conti in banca. Lascia che ti spieghi
quindi che cosa è successo, perché è
successo e perché questa cosa si
espanderà e andrà addirittura a toccare
i nostri portafogli. Salve a tutti,
Marco Casario qui, sono l'autore del
libro Investire nel breve, nel lungo
termine e recentemente la prima ministra
ormai ufficiale
Sanae Takaichi ha fatto una mossa che
nessuno si aspettava. ha convocato le el
lezioni anticipate per l'8 febbraio,
elezioni che poi ha vinto, anzi che ha
stravinto anche grazie alle promesse
fatte agli elettori di qualcosa di
irresistibile, cioè sospendere la tassa
sui consumi alimentari dell'8%,
aumentare la spesa pubblica, dare più
stimoli, più sussidi, insomma più soldi
per tutti. Bellissimo, no? Beh, c'è solo
un piccolo problema che il Giappone ha
un debito pubblico del 237% del prodotto
interno lordo, il più alto di qualsiasi
altro paese sviluppato al mondo.
L'Italia, che tutti considerano un
disastro fiscale, sta a circa il 140%.
Gli Stati Uniti, che tutti dicono che
sta andando incontro all'orlo del
baratro, stanno al 125%, il Giappone al
237. Bene, cosa ha fatto la Takaichi?
Quello che ha detto è semplice. Tagliamo
le tasse e spendiamo di più, senza dire
però da dove arriveranno i soldi. E lo
sai che cosa significa questo? Una cosa
sola. più debito, più titoli di stato da
emettere, più prestiti da chiedere al
mercato. Eh, il mercato ha detto no
violentemente, o meglio, il mercato
obbligazionario giapponese che infatti è
crollato. I rendimenti del titolo di
stato a 40 anni sono schizzati di 25
punti base in una sola sessione. E tu
potresti pensare, ma 25 punti base, lo
0,25% che sarà mai? Beh, nel mercato
obbligazionario giapponese, dove i
rendimenti si muovono di frazioni di
punti base al giorno, dove a volte ci
vogliono mesi per vedere un movimento di
10 punti base, lasciami dire che 25
punti base in 6 ore è praticamente un
terremoto. I rendimenti del trentennale
sono saltati a 3,9%, il più alto mai
registrato nella storia. Il decennale è
arrivato al 235%,
il livello più alto dal 1999. Tutto
questo è avvenuto in una sessione, in un
giorno, è stato il reprising più
violento del debito sovrano dai tempi di
Leedz Trust nel Regno Unito nel 2022. E
tra poco ti spiego anche perché questo
parallelo è fondamentale. Però prima
dobbiamo capire una cosa. Il Giappone
non è un paese qualunque nella finanza
globale. Il Giappone è stato per 30 anni
l'ammortizzatore finanziario del mondo
intero. Lo ha detto Nichael Green,
l'amministratore delegato della Vera
Group con una frase che suonava così:
"Il Giappone è stato l'ammortizzatore
finanziario del mondo per un'intera
generazione e quel ruolo è finito. È
finito per sempre". Che cosa si intende
per ammortizzatore finanziario? Vuol
dire che per 30 anni il Giappone ha
avuto i tassi di interesse più bassi del
pianeta. Non bassi tipo l'1%, no, bassi
tipo lo 0%, addirittura talvolta
negativi. I tassi negativi sono un
concetto assurdo, se ci pensi, cioè tu
mi presti €1000 e io te ne restituisco
900. Perché qualcuno dovrebbe accettare?
perché è il più grande prestatore del
governo giapponese. Indovinate un po'
chi era? La banca centrale del Giappone
che eseguiva gli ordini del governo e
poteva quindi giustificare queste
perdite perché si era in un regime di
deflazione, cioè l'inflazione era
negativa e questo sistema di soldi
gratis ha creato qualcosa di enorme,
qualcosa che ha alimentato ogni singolo
mercato finanziario del mondo per 15
anni. si chiama Carry Trade e funziona
così. In pratica prendi in prestito Yen
a 0%, li converti, li cambi in dollari
americani o in euro e li investi in
qualsiasi cosa che ti renda di più, per
esempio azioni americane, per esempio
titoli di stato americani, per esempio
nell'immobiliare oppure nelle
criptovalute oppure nel private equity.
Se il tuo investimento rende il 6% tu
hai preso in prestito al 0% e il 6% è
tutto profitto. E se addirittura lo fai
con una leva 10 ad un quel 6% diventa
60%. Pensate che Goldman Sax stima che
ci siano 450 miliardi di dollari legati
direttamente a strategie di carry trade,
ma il numero vero è molto più grande
perché gli investitori giapponesi hanno
circa
trilion investiti all'estero. 5 trilion
in titoli di stato americani, in
obbligazioni europee, in azioni, di
tutto. E ogni volta che c'era una crisi
negli ultimi 15 anni, ogni volta che i
mercati scendevano, il carry trade
entrava in gioco. Cioè gli investitori
giapponesi che prendevano in prestito
yen gratis e compravano il ribasso
stabilizzavano il prezzo fornendo
liquidità al sistema. Quindi il Carry
Trade lo possiamo immaginare come la
banca centrale ombra di tutti gli asset
a rischio del mondo. Ma adesso con i
rendimenti giapponesi che salgono, con
il decennale al 235%
e il quarantennale quasi al 4% la
matematica del carry trade non funziona
più. Perché se prendi in prestito yen
allo 0%, lo yen si rafforza del 10%, hai
perso 10% sulla valuta. Pure se il tuo
investimento è salito e se sei a leva
10, quel 10% di perdita valutaria ti
spazza via tutto il capitale, ti arriva
la margin call, sei costretto a vendere,
devi vendere le azioni americane, devi
vendere le criptovalute, devi vendere
l'immobiliare, devi ricomprare yen per
ripagare il debito. E quando tutti lo
fanno contemporaneamente, ecco che si
crea un effetto cascata, una spirale di
liquidazione. I prezzi crollano, le
margin call si intensificano, più
vendite, prezzi più bassi, più margin
tutto si autoalimenta. Però aspetta
perché qui entra in gioco l'elezione,
quella dell'altro giorno dove la
Takaichi ha vinto, non ha solo vinto, ha
stravinto perché il suo partito, l'LDP,
ha ottenuto più di 2/3 dei seggi alla
camera bassa, una super maggioranza.
significa che può governare senza
coalizione, senza compromessi, senza
nessuno che le dica di rallentare. E
questo potrebbe essere un problema
grande perché il suo predecessore, che
era più conservatore fiscalmente, che
voleva mettere in ordine i conti, che
voleva ridurre il debito, era molto
impopolare, la gente non lo voleva. E
questo è un pattern che vediamo un po'
ovunque nel mondo in questo momento. Lo
vediamo in Francia, lo vedremo nel Regno
Unito, lo vediamo negli Stati Uniti. Chi
taglia la spesa pubblica perde le
elezioni, chi promette di spendere le
vince. Però attenzione ad una cosa, non
è che sto dicendo che la Takaichi ha
vinto solo perché ha promesso soldi
facili, ha vinto perché i giapponesi
hanno paura per la prima volta dal 1945,
non possono più contare ciecamente sugli
americani. Trump è imprevedibile. La
Cina costruisce sottomarini e il
Giappone importa quasi tutto il suo cibo
e la sua energia. Se la Cina decidesse
di bloccare le rotte commerciali, il
Giappone potrebbe letteralmente morire
di fame. Il 92% dei giovani giapponesi
appoggia la Takaichi, 92%.
Perché lei promette una cosa che nessun
grafico di borsa può darti, la
sicurezza. E poi il suo partito vince
perché è stato incredibilmente reattivo.
Negli anni 70 è diventato ambientalista,
negli anni 90 ha fatto lo stimolo
fiscale, nel 2012 ha portato Abe e la
sua Abenomics, ora porta la Takaichi e
la sua sicurezza. È un partito che dà
alla gente quello che vuole e questo è
rilevante perché spiega perché il debito
cresce. Ogni crisi genera una risposta
fiscale e la risposta fiscale genera il
debito e il debito genera la prossima
crisi. E questo ci porta ad una
conclusione terrificante. Il problema
del debito è politicamente irrisolvibile
nelle democrazie. Nessun politico, in
nessun paese vi dirà, "Vi do meno soldi"
e vincerà le elezioni Ratakaichi lo ha
di nuovo dimostrato. Ha promesso più
spesa, meno tasse, nessuna fonte di
finanziamento e ha ottenuto la più
grande maggioranza parlamentare della
storia recente del Giappone. Sentivo il
commento del Stephen Nagi, il professore
dell'International Christian University
di Tokyo, che ha fatto un'osservazione
illuminante subito dopo la vittoria. ha
detto che le vere priorità dei
giapponesi non sono la costituzione
pacifista o l'immigrazione, sono i
salari, l'inflazione ed un ambiente
migliore per le famiglie e Takaichi
dovrà rispondere a queste priorità, ma
il modo in cui intende farlo spendendo
di più è esattamente ciò che ha fatto
esplodere il mercato obbligazionario. E
qui c'è un parallelo che nessuno sta
facendo e che è fondamentale. Atakaichi
e Trump tutto sommato vogliono la stessa
cosa. Vogliono una valuta locale debole.
Trump lo dice da mesi. Voglio un dollaro
più debole per rendere le esportazioni
americane competitive. La Takashi ha
detto la stessa identica cosa sullo yen.
Uno yen debole rende le aziende
giapponesi competitive all'estero. Le
Toyota costeranno meno, l'elettronica si
venderà meglio, che è tutto bellissimo
in teoria, ma c'è un problema
devastante. Quando la tua valuta si
indebolisce, tutto quello che importi
costa di più e il Giappone importa l'80%
della sua energia, petrolio, gas, viene
tutto da fuori. Uno yen debole significa
bollette più care, benzina più cara,
cibo più caro e l'inflazione in Giappone
è già al 3,1%
sopra il target della banca centrale da
4 anni consecutivi. E c'è pure un dato
che nessuno cita mai, ma che è una bomba
orologeria. Il 79% dei mutui in Giappone
è fatto a tasso variabile. Considerate
che negli Stati Uniti questa percentuale
è meno del 10%. In Italia sappiamo bene
che cosa vuol dire avere un mutuo
variabile quando i tassi salgono, perché
l'abbiamo vissuto nel 2022 e 23 con la
BCE che alzava. Ecco, in Giappone il
fenomeno è otto volte più grande. Se i
tassi continuano a salire, il 79% delle
famiglie con mutuo si ritrova con rate
più alte e se non hanno il reddito per
sostenerle arrivano i default, arrivano
le forlosure, arriva una crisi
immobiliare stile 2008 americano, però
in Giappone. Ora cerchiamo di guardare
un attimo al quadro complessivo. Da una
parte abbiamo un governo che vuole
spendere di più senza però avere i
soldi. Dall'altra abbiamo un mercato
obbligazionario che si è ribellato. In
mezzo c'è una banca centrale che è
intrappolata perché se tieni i tassi
bassi l'inflazione accelera e lo yen
crolla. Se alza i tassi, il debito
diventa insostenibile e il 79% dei
mutuari va in crisi. Questa trappola ha
un nome ed è un pattern che è diviso in
quattro stadi. Si è ripetuto identico
ogni singola volta in ogni paese
sviluppato che ha perso il controllo sul
mercato del debito. Il primo stadio si
chiama l'accumulo, cioè il governo
accumula debito oltre i livelli
sostenibili. in Giappone ci ha messo 30
anni. 30 anni di deficit, pacchetti di
stimolo che non funzionavano, promesse
agli elettori e ai pensionati che non
potevano essere finanziate con le tasse
fino ad arrivare al 237% del prodotto
interno lordo. Secondo stadio, la
dipendenza. Il governo diventa
dipendente dal fatto che i rendimenti
restino bassi, perché se i rendimenti
salgono il costo degli interessi
esplode. Il debito giapponese è circa 1
trilionar.
All'1% di interesse sono 130 miliardi
l'anno. Sì, è tanto, però è gestibile.
Ma al 4% sono 520 miliardi, praticamente
1/4 dell'intero bilancio del governo
giapponese solo per pagare gli
interessi, non per il capitale, per i
programmi, per le pensioni, per
l'istruzione, no, solo interessi. E per
mantenere i rendimenti bassi. La Banca
del Giappone ha fatto qualcosa che non
ha precedenti dal 2016 al 2024 ha
comprato titoli di stato in modo
illimitato, controllando direttamente la
curva dei rendimenti. Qual è stato il
risultato? che oltre il 50% di tutti i
titoli di stato giapponesi erano in mano
alla banca centrale, non agli
investitori privati, non ai fondi
pensioni, non alle famiglie, alla banca
centrale. E quando la banca centrale
possiede metà del debito del proprio
governo, quello non è un mercato, quello
è un meccanismo di controllo, dominanza
fiscale si chiama. Terzo stadio, la
rottura. Ed è qui che siamo adesso.
Qualcosa fa scattare il mercato,
qualcosa fa cambiare la psicologia da
accettazione
calma a paura. Per il Giappone è stata
la combinazione delle elezioni della
Takaichi e delle sue promesse di spesa.
Il 21 gennaio i rendimenti infatti sono
esplosi. Il 22 gennaio un'altra asta
debole sui ventennali. Nessuno li vuole
comprare a rendimenti ragionevoli. Il 28
gennaio il segretario del tesoro
americano Bensent chiama il suo omologo
giapponese esprimendo preoccupazione. La
Fed di New York conduce dei rate check
sullo yen segnalando possibili
interventi. Il 3 febbraio un'altra asta
obbligazionarie debole sul decennale con
il rendimento al 2,25%.
40 punti base più alto dell'asta di
dicembre. E quando la rottura inizia nei
mercati obbligazionari, il cosiddetto
reprising, il riprezzamento è violento,
veloce, brutale. Miliardi liquidati in
ore e questo meccanismo si autoalimenta.
Le vendite generano altre vendite, i
rendimenti che salgono generano
rendimenti ancora più alti. E poi
arriviamo al quarto stadio, il contagio.
Ed è qui che la storia giapponese
diventa la nostra storia, perché il
Giappone detiene più di 1,2 trilion
dollar in titoli di stato americani. È
il più grande detentore straniero di
debito americano. Per 30 anni il
Giappone ha riciclato il suo surplus
commerciale in tre giurie americani,
comprando obbligazioni, finanziando il
deficit americano, tenendo bassi i tassi
di interesse negli Stati Uniti. Ma
adesso che i titoli giapponesi rendono
il 2,25% sul decennale e quasi il 4% sul
quarantennale, perché un investitore
giapponese dovrebbe comprare titoli di
stato americani al 4% con rischio
valutario quando li può comprare titoli
giapponesi con lo stesso rendimento
nella propria valuta senza rischio di
cambio? La risposta è non lo farà più.
venderà i treasury americani, comprerà
titoli giapponesi, fa tornare il
capitale e Goldman Sax ha quantificato
questo meccanismo. Ogni 10 punti base di
stress sul decennale giapponese spinge i
rendimenti americani di 23 punti base
con i titoli di stato giapponesi che si
sono mossi di 25 punti base in una
sessione. con 5- set punti base di
pressione istantanea sui tre giori
americani e non si ferma lì perché
quando il più grande compratore
straniero diventa un venditore, gli
altri detentori esteri guardano e si
chiedono "Se il Giappone sta vendendo
perché io dovrei continuare a comprare e
quindi vendono pure loro più vendite, i
rendimenti si alzano e il ciclo è
vizioso". Ora questo pattern l'abbiamo
già visto, non è nuovo recentemente per
due volte e entrambe le volte è finita
male. La prima volta è stato nel Regno
Unito. Settembre del 2022 lit Trust
divenne prima ministra. In tre settimane
il suo cancelliere annuncia il mini
budget. 45 miliardi di sterline di tagli
fiscali non finanziati. Abbolire
l'aliquota massima, tagliare le tasse
alle aziende con nessuna copertura. Il
rendimento del trentennale britannico
schizza dal 3 e5 al 4,5% in 3 giorni. I
fondi di pensione che usavano quei
titoli come collaterale si sono
ritrovate con le margin call. La Bank of
England è stata costretta a intervenire
con acquisti illimitati. La sterlina è
crollata da 1,12 a 1,03 con contro il
dollaro americano. I mutui sono passati
dal 3 al 6% in poche settimane. Che cosa
è successo? che la Tr si è dimessa dopo
soli 44 giorni. La seconda volta che è
successa un po' prima in Grecia, dal
2010 al 2015. Stessa sequenza, debito
accumulato per anni grazie ai tassi
artificialmente bassi dell'euro. Poi la
rivelazione che il deficit era il doppio
di quanto dichiarato e i rendimenti
esplodono dal 5 al 12% in pochi mesi,
poi al 21%. Ci sono due bailout,
salvataggi, default. I privati prendono
un Aircut del 75%
per non perdere i loro investimenti. Il
prodotto interno lordo greco crolla del
25%. La disoccupazione arriva al 27%,
quella giovanile sopra il 60. Pensioni
tagliate del 40-50%,
controllo sui capitali, massimo €60 al
giorno dal bancomat. Il contagio si è
diffuso. I rendimenti portoghesi
schizzarono dal 4 al 16%. L'Irlanda ebbe
bisogno di un bailout da 85 miliardi. I
costi di finanziamento della Spagna
raggiunsero il 7%, un livello
considerato insostenibile e i rendimenti
italiani si avvicinarono a livelli molto
simili. Fu in quel periodo che Mario
Draghi, presidente della BCE, pronunciò
il famoso Whatever It Takes, luglio
2012, per fermare la spirale. E noi
italiani ce lo ricordiamo bene perché lo
spread BTP Bund saliva ogni giorno, i
telegiornali aprivano sempre con quel
numero, con la sensazione che il paese
potesse finire come la Grecia. Ecco,
quel meccanismo è molto simile a quello
che si sta attivando oggi. Però questa
volta la Miccia non è un paese
periferico dell'eurozona, è la quarta
economia del mondo con 13 milioni di
debito, con 1000 miliardi in treasury
americani, integrata in ogni singolo
mercato finanziario del pianeta. Quando
il mercato obbligazionario del Giappone
si rompe, il contagio è globale,
immediato e molto difficile da fermare.
E qui arriviamo alla domanda che ci
interessa di più. Cosa significa tutto
questo per noi poveri investitori
italiani? Prima cosa, se hai
investimenti in ETF, azioni denominati
in dollari e il dollaro si indebolisce
perché Trump lo vuole debole e perché il
Giappone non compra più Treasury, il
nostro rendimento in euro si erode. è
successo nel 2025, perché tu puoi avere
un ETF sull' S&P 500 che sale del 5% in
dollari, ma se il dollaro perde l'8%
contro l'euro, hai perso il 3% in
termini reali, quindi sempre più
importante diventa una protezione nel
portafoglio dal rischio di cambio.
Tecniche di protezione esistono, possono
essere implementate, tra l'altro è la
prima protezione che spiego nel mio
percorso portfolio mastery in aula 3
giorni insieme. Secondo punto, se il
contagio si estende all'Europa e gli
spread si allargano, come accade nel
2011-2012, l'Italia è nel mirino. Siamo
il paese con il debito più alto
dell'eurozzona, secondi solo alla
Grecia. Se i mercati iniziano a
chiedersi chi sarà il prossimo, eh la
risposta potrebbe essere saremo noi? E
questo significherà rendimenti dei BTP
più alti, mutui variabili più cari e
pressione sulla BCE per decidere se
intervenire o no. Terzo punto, i tassi
più alti globalmente significano che il
costo del credito sale ovunque. Mutui,
prestiti auto, carte di credito.
L'intera economia globale è costruita
sul credito a basso costo e il credito a
basso costo richiede che ci siano
compratori esteri, specialmente
giapponesi, a finanziare il debito. Se
il Giappone smette di comprare, il costo
del credito sale in tutto il mondo. Però
fermiamoci un attimo perché c'è una cosa
importante, una logica nascosta in tutto
questo che porta ad un'unica
conclusione. Qualunque cosa faccia la
Banca Centrale del Giappone, qualunque
decisione prenda la Takaichi, l'esito
finale sarà sempre lo stesso. Se alzano
i tassi scatenano una crisi e le banche
centrali rispondono alle crisi stampando
moneta. La Fed riavvia il quantityasing,
la BCE riavvia il quantitying, la
liquidità in ononda il sistema e quella
liquidità finisce negli asset reali,
nell'oro, nell'argento,
nell'immobiliare. Se invece non alzano i
tassi, se continuano a stampare la
svalutazione della valuta, continua la
corsa al ribasso continua e l'oro,
l'argento, gli asset tangibili
proteggono anche da quello. Lo capisci
il meccanismo? è un po' un imbuto. Tutte
le strade portano allo stesso posto. Non
è un caso che l'oro è di nuovo ai
$5.000, ha raggiunto il massimo storico
durante la crisi giapponese di fine
gennaio e potrebbe continuare a salire
nel tempo. Ma anche se non salisse,
anche se restasse stabile, mentre tutto
il resto perde il 20%, quella è già una
vittoria. Poi c'è la domanda ancora più
profonda, no? Che nessuno dei grafici e
dei numeri può a cui può rispondere. Il
Giappone può convivere con l'inflazione
perché per 30 anni i giapponesi hanno
vissuto in un mondo dove i prezzi non si
muovevano, dove potevi andare al
supermercato e sapere esattamente quanto
costava il riso, le uova, il gelato,
dove un aumento di centeva
una conferenza stampa di scuse ufficiali
e adesso improvvisamente i prezzi
salgono del 3 del 4%. I salari nominali
crescono, sì, ma i salari reali, quelli
aggiustati per l'inflazione, sono in
calo. E quel 3% di aumento medio
nasconde una realtà. Per qualcuno è il
5%, per qualcun altro è l'1% e per
qualcuno è lo zero. E quel qualcuno con
lo 0% di aumento e il 3% di inflazione
per quel qualcuno sarà sofferenza. Il
governo ha risposto, come rispondono
tutti i governi, con i sussidi. Sussidi
per l'energia, sussidi per il cibo,
contromisure per attutire il colpo del
costo della vita. Ma i sussidi non sono
gratis, vengono finanziati con altro
debito in un paese che ha già il debito
più alto del mondo sviluppato e intanto
i giapponesi stanno cambiando i loro
comportamenti. Il governo ha creato
programmi fiscali agevolati, si chiamano
NISA, che permettono di investire in
azioni con vantaggi fiscali e i
giapponesi che per decenni hanno tenuto
i risparmi in depositi bancari a
rendimento zero stanno spostando i soldi
nel mercato azionario. Il Nickei ha
raggiunto massimi storici nel 2025, ma
questo crea un nuovo rischio. Se il
mercato crolla non non colpisce più solo
gli investitori professionali, colpisce
le famiglie normali che hanno messo i
risparmi in borsa per la prima volta. E
il Giappone ha un problema che aggrava
tutto, l'invecchiamento.
È una delle popolazioni più anziane del
mondo, pensioni che non bastano per
vivere, sempre meno lavoratori per
sostenere il sistema. un paese che
invecchia con pensioni insufficienti in
un mondo di inflazione crescente e le
aziende giapponesi stanno cambiando pure
loro. Per decenni il Giappone era
un'economia orientata agli stakeholder,
cioè le aziende esistevano per servire i
dipendenti, i fornitori, i clienti, la
comunità. I profitti erano secondari,
gli azionisti erano un pensiero lontano,
le aziende sedevano su una montagna di
liquidità, rifiutavano di pagare i
dividendi, rifiutavano di fare buyback,
ma adesso, sotto pressione degli
investitori attivisti, del governo, di
una nuova generazione di manager, il
Giappone sta diventando un'economia
shareholder first, come gli Stati Uniti,
dividendi in aumento, buy back, vendita
di asset non strategici, focus sulla
redditività e questo rende le azioni
giappon
attraenti. Per la prima volta in 30 anni
gli investitori esteri stanno guardando
al Giappone e vedono valore. Ma
attenzione perché questa è un'arma a
doppio taglio. Se il Giappone diventa
attraente, se i rendimenti
obbligazionari giapponesi diventano
competitivi, se le azioni giapponesi
offrono valore a multipli bassi, il
capitale torna in Giappone, esce dagli
Stati Uniti, esce dall'Europa e
quell'uscita di capitale è esattamente
ciò che fa crollare i mercati
occidentali. È un'inversione di 40 anni
di flussi di capitali. Quell'inversione
se accelera cambia tutto. E allora cosa
possiamo fare? Come possiamo
posizionarci? Io non ti posso dare dei
consigli finanziari, non sono il tuo
consulente finanziario, ti posso dare
dei principi su cui puoi riflettere. Il
primo, capire che questo problema non è
confinato al Giappone. L'integrazione
dei mercati finanziari globali significa
che il contagio è automatico, è
meccanico. Quando la quarta economia del
mondo perde il controllo del suo mercato
obbligazionario, tutto si riperezza. I
tuoi fondi pensione, i tuoi ETF, i tuoi
BTP. Secondo, diversifica per davvero,
non 100% in azionario, non 100% in
obbligazionario, 100% in niente, in un
ambiente dove non sai da che parte
romperà il mercato. La diversificazione
non è un lusso, è una questione di
sopravvivenza.
Azioni, obbligazioni a breve termine,
liquidità, immobiliare, materie prime,
oro. Terzo punto, guarda lo yen. Lo yen
è il sistema di allarme anticipato. Se
lo yen si rafforza improvvisamente è il
mercato che prezza un rialzo dei tassi,
è il carry trade che si sgretola, è il
segnale per diventare difensivi. Se lo
Yeny indebolisce invece gli asset
rischiosi potrebbero avere ancora
margine di salita. Quarto punto,
considera l'esposizione al Giappone. Se
credi che la normalizzazione sia reale,
che il Giappone faccia sul serio, le
azioni giapponesi a 12 volte gli utili
con una governance in miglioramento sono
un valore migliore delle azioni
americani a 22 volte gli utili, però
pesala come rischio, non come una
scommessa. Quinto punto, guarda i
metalli preziosi, oro, argento, platino,
perché qualunque scenario si
materializzi, la risposta finale delle
banche centrali è sempre la stessa,
stampare moneta. E quando stampi moneta
svaluti la valuta. E quando svaluti la
valuta l'oro è l'unica protezione. Però
attenzione perché c'è anche l'altro lato
della medaglia. C'è chi dice che la
spesa di Taka della Takaichi non è spesa
buttata, è spesa investita in difesa. E
la difesa rivitalizza il manifatturiero,
attrae investimenti americani, spinge
l'adozione dell'intelligenza
artificiale, elimina gli stimoli
inefficienti. Se funziona il Giappone
potrebbe uscire da 30 anni di
stagnazione proprio grazie a questa
crisi. Il punto è funzionerà abbastanza
velocemente prima che il mercato
obbligazionario perdi la pazienza. E lo
so, vedete, ragionandoci questo può
sembrare tutto estremamente lontano, no?
Il Giappone è dall'altra parte del
mondo. Sì, un gelato che costa se cent
in più non sembra una notizia che
dovrebbe farci alzare dalla sedia, ma la
verità che quel gelato, quell'economia è
l'inizio di una storia che passa per
Tokyo, attraversa Wall Street gli Stati
Uniti, arriva a Francoforte e finisce
nel nostro estratto conto. Perché
viviamo in un mondo dove una decisione
presa in una sala riunioni a Tokyo alle
3:00 di notte, ora italiana, può far
salire il tasso del tuo mutuo variabile
in pochi mesi, dove il più grande
detentore straniero del debito americano
che decide di vendere può far crollare
il valore del nostro ETF All World o
l'S&P 500, dove una prima ministra
giapponese che promette più spesa senza
coperture può far allargare lo spread
BTP Bund. Non perché il mondo sia
fragile, ma perché il mondo è
interconnesso.
Ogni filo tira un altro filo e il
Giappone ha appena tirato il filo più
grande. Bene, grazie mille per
l'attenzione. È stato un video lungo, ma
ci tenevo a farlo perché questi
meccanismi sono importanti prima di
tutto da capire e la conoscenza, la
consapevolezza è l'unica vera arma per
noi investitori.